what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here john how are you i'm so good
andrew i'm doing well all right guys well we got
ourselves an official trailer for the disney plus
show tales of the jedi and it looks like uh clone
wars animation style so let's get into it and see
what's going on also you know use the force to
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
everywhere there is life but you must face death
honor it
do not fear it baby soccer jedi ahsoka is jedi
the best way i can protect you is
to teach you how to protect yourself
i'm so cool i want to bring peace
dooku as a jedi sweet why gone it is
the only way you will truly have victory
why you better one wow dang he doesn't look
like he's cool he does look like a young
again oh so excited to see them again
stand down
i've been warning them about the coming darkness
let's hope pays off mr rex
and who might you be
oh awesome
yeah that looks exciting yeah it looks really
exciting that's cool man i like what the star
wars have been doing with their animation
department of you know you had visions which
i thought i mean i think we both liked it quite
a bit i didn't feel like i got enough traction
but this obviously i feel like we get way
more traction considering the fact that these
this is the like the clone war style i mean you're
you're bringing back ahsoka and anakin and looking
at the early days of them training together
i mean i think the most exciting part though
is you get to see dooku as a jedi for the first
time that's like a long overdue story that yeah
you'd think that by now we would have seen
it and it's just like wow watch us oh damn
we've never seen that that's pretty crazy so yeah
i think there's a lot to look forward to here and
it does feel like still sprawling and and it feels
uh well intimate you know it's not the word i
thought i'd be associating with this yeah so yeah
but uh john yeah no this this definitely looked
exciting i mean as somebody who has you know is
been sort of steeping into the clone wars universe
and then looking at all the different live-action
things this is kind of like a cool convergence
point for me because the clone wars was like
a very formidable prospect to me at the outset
and this takes that but it also combines it with
some very familiar and you know iconic characters
from the live action stuff as well that's like
directly accessible to that so you have like the
tutelage of qui-gon jinn and things like that and
i would love to see yeah that history along with
the expansion on that beloved back and forth
between ahsoka and anakin and just any kind of
peripheral details i feel like you free yourself
up in a way to tell interesting uh you know more
complex perhaps stories when you're in sort of a
slightly anthological scenario so uh yeah i mean
i loved the blend of tones that we're looking
at here you know like it looks appropriately
intense and fun but there's also some stuff that
looks a little more somber and cinematic and a
little more akin to the movie side as well as the
clone wars aspects so yeah this looks super cool
ginger ever since may 2002 when i saw everyone's
favorite film attack at the clones in theaters
uh there was a line in that movie which really got
me like really just playing things in my mind like
i want to see that story was when count dooku said
to obi-wan kenobi when he was in that that holding
chamber he said that he was qui-gon jinn's master
i was like man i've always wanted and i'd love to
see a story where we get to see that him training
qui-gon or at least some flashbacks something so
when i heard the idea of this i was like
wow this has me intrigued but actually
like seeing it now in trailer form like man
this is so cool just seeing that hilt and
that lightsaber i'm like that's awesome because
obviously that's he had the red lightsaber but
yeah i know this looks really cool and i
like how they really get that look down of
uh of uh qui-gon jin it looks like a really young
liam neeson but i'm really intrigued that but
i think the thing that was really
uh interesting to me as well was
just seeing dooku like drawing like he's always
had a little bit of a dark side in him even
when he was uh a jedi like you had to see uh
samuel jackson's uh mace windu you had to see
you had to see mace windu tell him like dooku stop
and i just thought that was like okay look he's
always had a little dark side in him he's always
on that edge of you know like struggling between
that line of good and evil so i'm really looking
forward to this and yeah i really want to see too
if i'm not sure if they're gonna have time to show
like i'm not sure like how they're gonna do the
tales of time in this but i'm really curious to
see i want to see qui-gon train obi-wan kenobi
as well i want to see get get some glimpses of
that because i've always been intrigued with that
because we only got the tail end of that when
we saw the phantom menace in 99 so i'm really
intrigued at the thought of the notion of seeing
that as well qui-gon and uh dooku jeez we're
reminded right now so many names in the star wars
so many names right dooku and qui-gon i'm really
intrigued at that but i also want to see obi-wan
kenobi and qui-gon as well i'm really intrigued
with the notion of that and ahsoka uh sokatano and
uh obi and anakin skywalker yeah so many names one
might do so many but anakin and ahsoka i'm really
i love that relationship too and i'm so glad they
got ashley eckstein back she is she just embodies
the voice of a soccer tone ahsoka tona and uh
i'm on it right now i'm on it guys she she really
embodies the voice of the character and as much
as i love rosario dawson in the live-action form
uh ashley eckstein is is this character to me and
i'm really i'm really really interested to
see her back as well but also seeing that
relationship just expand more between her and
anakin because i love that relationship it's a
really endearing relationship for me yeah
i mean in the final season of clone wars
2. by the way i don't want to cut up anything you
said i thought that was it's got to stay raw it's
all the correct names was beautiful
stumbling is the best best the best
discussions like running down a flight
of stairs when you're leaning too far
forward but you can't stop remember
everything correctly andrew do it dude
um no i think i think ahsoka and uh anakin we
because of the final season and what they had
to tell in that final season when the show got uh
resurrected for disney plus we didn't really get
much of them together just because of the specific
story they had to tell and i and i think that with
getting a a taste of again of the beginnings
with them is delightful all right tails the jedi
this is the first video we shot today and this is
our warm-up their warm-up let's see if this goes
live i like the trailer that was awesome i thought
it was good all right guys t23 we're killing it